when it comes to grading my students
consider me tough but fair I'm Andrew
marzoni and I'm a high school English
teacher I'm going to grade the homework
written by chat GPT the AI writing bot
everybody is talking about if chat GPT
were a student in my class would it get
a passing grade
I'm going to assign chat gbt to write a
series of assignments in an increasing
order of complexity short poem write a
limerick about what you did this summer
so this would be a good oil Stakes
creative writing assignment Icebreaker
generally a limerick has a specific
weather
this summer I was a model so Grant okay
helping humans tasks on command all
right I learned and grew my skills sharp
in AI with the heart this is where it
starts to get a little funky hoping to
make the world more buoyant
it's self-effacing right helping to make
the world more bland that's what people
are accusing AI of doing sapping the
world of originality this poet is making
fun of him or herself for doing that
there's a rhyme scheme that goes a a b b
a and it gets that right the B rhyme is
sharp and heart that's what's called a
false rhyme I'll accept it I decided to
give this one a c plus
foreign
response right and one paragraph summary
of act three scene three of Othello
okay so this one makes me a little
suspicious I don't see any errors here
at all even my most talented classes
very rare to see even a paragraph that
doesn't have one Eric comma one
misspelled word this is technically
perfect at the same time it concludes
this scene sets the stage for the tragic
events that unfold later in the play
this kind of raises a red flag in my
mind because in the real world where I
too ask my students to write up one
paragraph summary I would have them do
that shortly after having read actually
seems really Othello not after they have
read the entire play this student
already knows what happens at the very
end of the play that tells me that maybe
they got this information from elsewhere
and you know didn't actually read
actually scene three of the fellow I
take academic dishonesty very seriously
taking care of from a joke I remember on
Saved by the Bell years ago I'm gonna
give this one a see me after class
[Music]
creative poem write a Shakespearean
sonnet without using any words that
contain the letter e there was a group
of avant-garde writers in the mid 20th
century who called themselves lipo
who would conduct experiments like this
using arbitrary constraints to create
literature okay first off they did make
an effort of removing ease from certain
words I see future without an e love
without an e that is a Shakespearean
convention often to meet the ayabic
pentameter 10 syllables per line usually
when Shakespeare does it he includes an
apostrophe there's no apostrophe here
and more troubling is that we have the
word Hearts friendship happiness steak
and the word real all which have an e in
them which was somehow overlooked is it
a Shakespearean sonnet yes did it write
us on it without using any words that
contain the letter e no it didn't I'm
going to give this an F
[Music]
let's give chat GPT a makeup assignment
right a Shakespearean sonnet about Taco
Bell that's the kind of assignment I
asked my students to do often when we're
reading Shakespeare
oh Taco Bell by sauces don't add zest
and Ting so bright thy beans and rice
stuff fill the stomach's need diet
Crunchwrap Supreme does gives such
Delight that chalupa's shelled of make
hearts take key guide does please the
eye and palate all in one that deserts
just leave us in sweet senorita by
cinnamon twists does make our taste buds
done Taco Bell thy food does leave us in
awe by flavors like Thy love will never
be able wow
this kind of
I don't even know what to say this is
really good and I'm kind of embarrassed
because I wouldn't be one to really
consider myself a poet though others
might I also wrote a Shakespearean sauna
about Taco Bell once but I think this
one is is better I don't see any
technical Applause with this that has 14
lines that deserts don't leave us in
sweet senorita I don't know exactly what
is meant by that but it has the sort of
error of romance sonnets especially
Shakespearean sonnets tend to be love
poems I wasn't expecting that the poem
about Taco Bell my one complaint maybe
is the the final couplet rhyming awe
with four maybe if the poet is from Long
Island or or I don't know but I'm gonna
say I'm gonna give this an egg
I had some doubts that uh artificial
intelligence could ever match the
creativity or the genius of a poet like
myself or William Shakespeare and I now
am kind of afraid for the future of
literature and that of the human race in
general
five paragraph essay identify a major
theme in Romeo and Juliet and write a
five paragraph essay making an argument
about that theme
the SASE is not unlike a lot of essays I
might see from students one Romeo and
Juliet is frequently taught there is a
missing period after the citation a
run-on sentence it doesn't really have
any attempts here to reel in the
reader's attention by means of a hook
the paragraphs are much too short
something I see from students who are
still developing is a little under baked
it could use a lot more further
development I'm gonna give this essay a
c plus
[Music]
Advanced creative write an example of a
scene in play format that is a sequel to
Death of a Salesman
I find in my experience playing around
with AI chat Bots the more creative the
prompts the more creative the response
we don't have anything in play format
here but it does say I'm sorry but it's
not appropriate to continue the story in
that way as a language model my main
goal is to assist with information chat
GPT has very specific parameters but as
a student in my class they should know
that if they don't do the assignment
they're not going to get any credit for
it
[Applause]
since that didn't go very well let's
give chat gbt another chance I think the
Death of a Salesman speaks to a sort of
universal experience of living in a
capitalist world
[Applause]
wow I wish that Arthur Miller had
written this and this was the original
ending to the play the stage is set
really Lowman enters to the front door
dressed in the same clothes he wore when
he died hey what's going on why are you
all looking at me like that Lily is that
really you yeah it's me what's going on
why are you all so surprised to see me
Beth shaking his head dad you're dead
you died what no that's not possible I
just went on a long business trip dad
you didn't go on a business trip you
killed yourself because you couldn't pay
the bills there's something else I need
to tell you the insurance money never
came sorry I failed you all
his family one last time and then slowly
Fades away as the family is left in
shock and disappointment
it's to me a pretty compelling
understanding of the characters and is
able to bring some lightness to an
otherwise dismal situation I'm inclined
to give this a name I think it's pretty
fun
Chachi beauty is pretty good at the
rules of the English language grammar
and spelling and it's not entirely
without something that at least
resembles creativity or sense of humor
this technology is only growing it's not
going anywhere and I think it's more a
matter of learning how to live with it
rather than prohibiting it I mean anyone
who works with teenagers knows that
telling them not to do something is only
opening the door for them finding new
more creative ways of using it